so of course we're still very much
dealing with the coronavirus pandemic
and in the midst of all of this the
united states
now has a monkey pox scare
where 200 americans are being monitored
and tracked for the rare disease
monkey pox more than 200 peop can you
imagine what's going on
more than 200 people in 27 u.s states
are being tracked for possible
rare monkey pox infections they fear
people may have come
into contact with the texas man who
brought the disease
in from nigeria earlier this month
the man believed to be the first monkey
pox case in the u.s since 2003
was taken to a hospital but is in a
stable condition
so far no new cases have been found
cdc is concerned passengers who were on
two flights the man-made
may have been exposed he flew into
atlanta georgia from lagos nigeria on
july 9th before taking a flight to
dallas
where he was hospitalized the chances of
the disease spreading on the plane were
low
because passengers had to wear face
masks
important detail that shouldn't be
ignored
um if you don't know much about monkey
pox and i didn't know that much about it
until i researched it today
monkey pox was first discovered in 1958
there were two outbreaks of a
pox-like disease so pox like chickenpox
smallpox pox-like
happened in colonies of monkeys that
were being kept
for research that's where the name
monkey pox came from
the first human case was recorded in
1970
and when we talk about contagious
disease we talk about the natural
reservoir
like where is monkey pox right now it
it's not known
but uh african rodent species are
suspected of playing a role
in transmission as the bbc article
stated the first u.s case was in 2003
there have been only 47 cases ever in
the u.s 200 people are now being
monitored
and that initial introduction in 2003
is believed to be because of a shipment
of animals
from ghana in humans the symptoms of
monkey pox
are similar to smallpox but not as
serious they start with fever headache
muscle aches and exhaustion
the main difference between smallpox
and monkeypox is that with monkeypox the
lymph nodes tend to swell
the incubation period meaning the time
from when you are infected to when you
have symptoms
is typically 7 to 14 days but
like with all of these things it's on a
bell curve and it can actually range
from 5 to 21
days within one to three days after the
start of fever
there will often be a rash often
starting in the face and then spreading
elsewhere it tends to be a two to four
week illness
in africa and this is a horrifying
number
in africa monkey pox has been shown to
cause death
in as many as 10 of those who are
infected 10
um and that just again brings us back to
so far the mortality the lethality
of covid is under one percent um
and we say you know imagine if we had a
flu with an eight percent
mortality rate or a ten percent okay the
virus enters through broken skin even if
the skin isn't
visibly broken it can enter through the
respiratory tract mucous membranes
meaning mucus membrane membranes
meaning eyes nose and mouth animal to
human transmission can be a bite or a
scratch
preparing meat contact with bodily
fluids
and the most common human to human
transmission
is primarily through large respiratory
droplets there is no proven safe
treatment for monkey pox virus at this
time
antivirus antivirals as well as
vaccinia immune globulin or vig can be
used to try to deal with
severity or symptoms so
this is like the absolute last thing we
need right now and of course because the
most common human to human transmission
method is large droplet
and right now because of the covid
pandemic
passengers on flights are required to
wear masks the hope is that none of the
200 passengers that have been identified
as exposed will actually end up being
infected but
not exactly the news that we were hoping
for that's for sure
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost
of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package
no driving around to the doctor's office
or the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa
the entire process is just a few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an
entire month's supply for free when you
use the promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping